they need the money when there's no war
40 percent of russian budget is digging
from the ground and selling it to other
people it's a wreakly ass economy with
no modern basis it's just the most
unsophisticated economy in the world
tom nash welcome to the show
welcome chris we could not have picked a
better time to talk
uh
i think that pretty much right now
is
2022 and yet somehow don't you feel like
this is 1960s and we're dealing with the
new crisis again i mean this is insane
what a time to be a russian man
yeah not not a good time to be a russian
to be honest uh
russia is cancelled i don't know if you
heard
literally
i mean i think putin miscalculated
cancel culture i've said it before and i
i said again he's too old to understand
how it works
like
we're cancelled everything yeah but
cancel culture up against a 200 000
person army
with missiles and an air force
surely that's not a big deal
look
even
hollywood who sent john cena to
apologize to china
is now not sending movies to russia bro
i mean
look at the countries i saw i said it
earlier today that voted with russia
on the on the u.n general assembly iran
syria
eritrea and belarus which for all
intents and purposes belarus is just
part of russia so
i mean you don't have a lot of friends
left my guy if you're putting
it's tough
there's the you know do you do you know
the channel no [ __ ]
no
so
uh no focus is it there's a russian
channel run by a guy named roman and he
spells it with
nfkrz that's how the channel name and
he's a really cool dude and he just made
a video showing exactly what it looks
like to get money off of atm in moscow
or sorry senpai saint petersburg
so basically
showing like a bunch of like 200 people
trying to get into the door into the
bank and the security guard and saying
there's no money here get the like post
apocalyptic scenes out of moscow and
saint petersburg basically no money in
the atms
nothing works credit cards don't work
pretty much
anywhere you have to pay with cash and i
mean you can't get it
now the crazy part is now there's new
regulation in russia
basically if you own any foreign
currency
you have
70 dollars or so to
exchange it to rubles like 80 of it you
can't keep it anymore so if you have in
your bank account if you had some
dollars or some euros or some gbp
what so what happens if you don't
convert
legal sanctions i mean you don't want to
test it out
if you're a law-abiding citizen
i mean look the problem is
what does what do central banks do
what's the main job of the central bank
to make sure that the state's parts of
currency doesn't go ballistic
it needs to be stable
the way you do it is you regulate it
like an oven
and the way you regulate it is with
buying and selling right
if your
state sponsored currency is going down
you buy some of it
and if you're going too much up you sell
some of it right
to do that you need
you need dollars
like
you need foreign currency to regulate
and if you don't have foreign currency
basically and there's a panic mode which
is definitely is the case right now
everybody's selling out that's why the
ruble is now rubble it's pretty much
it's nothing
because and that's why they're telling
you hey sell all your foreign currencies
because the central banks literally
needs just to take it from the citizens
right now oh somehow they need foreign
currency liquidity
from their citizens so that they can use
it to control their own so what's
happened to the state of the ruble
now
it's it's very close to
it's on the path to 1998.
what's that mean
that means the
hyperinflation so there's a few
economists who commented on this and i
can tell you from friends on the ground
that like prices of electronics have
gone like 40 up
within five days it's there's a lot of
economies that are saying that if this
continues for a few more days we're
looking at anywhere from 50 to 70
inflation
within a week bro
this is not 1984. when you take a
country off the grid
this is what happens
it basically money becomes worthless
hyperinflation and then you sell your
you know everything you own for your
next lunch
this is literally what happened in
russia in the late 90s
like we've seen this happen
and the the problem is that while 1998
happened russia was not
spending 20 billion dollars a day on the
war
which is something you also have to take
into account that war is costing a lot
of money
not to mention the fact that this
rickety-ass army is stuck in the mud
because of a logistical nightmare but i
mean even that you know whatever attempt
of i don't understand i'm not a military
strategist i don't understand this all
i'm saying i'm i'm a money guy this war
is expensive
and he just got [ __ ] blocked
from accessing any sort of foreign
currency all right so that was that was
his biggest mistake by the way let's go
from the absolute top people that don't
understand what's happened in terms of
financial sanctions
what the impacts have been what they
actually mean for russia uh this was
story about swift was gonna happen it
wasn't gonna happen now it's happening
like let's just take it from the top all
the way down what's happened financially
with regards to russia
you have to understand we're starting
from the middle of the story but we can
do it but we have to go back to the
origins take us from the tickets from
the start man go from there no no but
this is let's start with the middle then
go back so
putin's plan all along was basically
to create
a feud
between
nato
itself so nato is basically to be honest
three countries that dominate nato
u.s
it's germany and it's uh great britain
or england or uk whatever you want to
call it i get confused i never know what
the [ __ ] you guys are called bro
anyways so it's like switzerland which
language do they speak i don't
understand what are the nationality like
i'm so confused by switzerland bro like
what is this country like what's the
language well i think you're just have
you ever like swiss people bro they're
more confused than canadians and i love
swiss people and i love me some
canadians but check this out
basically putin said hey listen
the germans the germans they need me
now that they've basically shut down
nuclear reactors
and understand why they did it right and
they don't want to burn coal anymore out
of environmental concerns
they need my gas
and
i own them
because 60
of germany's energy is coming from
russia imagine having that kind of power
especially in the winter i don't know
how i look i you think you know how much
it's getting cold you you don't know
cold until you've seen like true german
call bro i mean i know you guys invented
the color damp over there in the uk but
i mean true german cold is like it's
it's vicious even now even in february
even in march it's going to be cold for
a while
now imagine having that sort of power if
you if you're russia and you're saying
and
on the flip side of it you have another
dominant nato member which is the us
which doesn't give a [ __ ] about putin's
energy they couldn't give less [ __ ]
about it
they were i thought that they were
relatively dependent on putin's energy
because they've shut down their own
energy independence
that's germany no i thought that america
was the same as well
america is energy independent which is
exactly where you want to be america has
their own natural gas they have their
own oil they have everything they need
internally they don't need to buy they
buy [ __ ] but i mean they're
energy independent which means they
don't need anybody else i thought that
they'd scaled back their production
their pipelines they were increasingly
dependent on russia are you saying that
that's not true
they don't they don't i don't exactly
know the numbers of how much they're
buying and selling but
once you have potential energy
independence it doesn't really matter i
don't know exactly how much they're
buying to my understanding
is not dependent it's nowhere near if
anything to what's going on in germany
in italy and then generally in the eu we
can look up the numbers later but i
don't think so
for years and years
the european union have been basically
trying to have this debate about well
everybody's too dependent on on russia
so
40 of the european gas consumption is is
russia and the worst of them all is
germany with 60
and they haven't done nothing about it
because i mean why would you it's cheap
gas it's convenient and you know it's
working why you know
why talk about something that might
happen one day right why prepare
so
when putin i think started this
that's why if okay let's divide the
world right you have the people who are
hawkish on putin which is the us
and you have the davis which is eu and
mainly germany up until just a few days
ago that's the way it always worked and
every time there's a little bit of a
problem germany disappeasing and
basically saying okay okay chill chill
chill and the u.s is like sanctioned sex
so putin knew that if he's gonna start
this turmoil in in ukraine whatever
happens he knew he's gonna get
sanctioned by the us
that's why he completely detolarized his
entire exports
he went from 95 dollars to 10 dollars
and
for the past four years
he'd been slowly prepping for this now
he he has some yens but mainly it's
euros
because he never thought
that the germans will basically say well
um i mean you're going too far because
they can't and there is a reason
why he did this when he did this
and the reason people saying oh it's
trump it's by it's not about trump or
biden
it's about inflation in the u.s
which is a 40-year high
which means they can't afford high oil
prices
and because even though they don't buy
really and we could check the numbers
later russian oil they buy [ __ ] that are
being produced with russian oil which
means they'll feel the the price and
besides you know oil is a global pricing
mechanism so it doesn't really matter so
he started this knowing that inflation
in the u.s is super high so they're
super sensitive to oil prices and also
in the winter so he knows that the
europeans don't want any interruption
right now
and he thought i think that his thought
process was well
i'm gonna
i'm gonna push in ukraine they're not
going to
interrupt me because ukraine is not nato
and they will not risk a nuclear war
with me for ukraine
and the germans are basically going to
get into a fight with the us
and then i'm going to destabilize nato
and i'm going to create a fight between
them and i'll take ukraine
and i'll be ready for u.s sanctions
because i'm completely in euros yeah so
the presumption was that germany wasn't
going to push back because of their
energy dependence on russia and that
america america would want to push back
because it's relatively energy
independent this would create conflict
between germany specifically as one of
them and america america wants more
sanctions germany wants fewer sanctions
there's your friction meanwhile you can
move forward is that what you're saying
the plan was financially
precisely and if you look at the first
few days
of the of the military operation this is
exactly how it played out you remember
how germany refused to allow anybody to
send german-made arms to ukraine in the
beginning and how they just agreed to
send some helmets over there
now germany has a long-standing embargo
on they don't send traditionally weapons
to conflict uh conflict regions because
of their history obviously
but uh you know
i mean there are a lot of explaining to
do but i mean
all i'm saying is so germany was
basically pushing back in the beginning
and
they were actually more closer to the
german position because when it started
the narrative was well if he stops
with these
pieces of ukraine which already de facto
owns let's be honest since 2014. if he
stops with lugansk and donetsk
we'll just let him have it
that was the sentiment and that was
being led by germany like
you know what [ __ ] it he already owns it
anyways he just makes it official we
don't care
and
i think that
his biggest miscalculation and i think
tell me if you think that's right chris
when you surround yourselves
with yes men and you completely kill
anybody within the poisoning opinion
you create this echo chamber where i
think nobody told them hey
the germans might push back
i don't think anybody in his team
actually told him that
and i don't know if you've seen this but
there's a very famous viral clip that's
circulating where he was interrogating
his own head of intelligence
about whether they should or should not
invade ukraine
and the guys like
and you're talking about the head the
main the head spy of russia so it's a
bad man it's not a
this is a killer bro okay
and he was basically up there and saying
well mr putin uh i think we should maybe
try and negotiate a little bit more he's
like and then he gave him the desk there
it's like
are you saying that we should negotiate
more i said no no no i don't i don't
like basically you could why was this
televised
oh he televised the whole thing there
was like this kangaroo horde so he put
all of them
like a
he was at the head of the table like 30
meters away they all got a chair and he
went one by one asking his head advisors
if they should invade ukraine so is that
basically a test of compliance it's will
you say yes to me when i want to do like
everybody knows what he wants to do is
he actually looking for pushback
it's a theater he's not looking for
pushback it's a theater right okay yes
that's that's that's what i mean can you
try just one thing that i've thought
there obviously you speak russian um and
for everybody else what we're doing is
we're looking at the subtitles or the
dubbing over the top how would you
characterize
putin's demeanor with the way that he
speaks
you know we have people like barack
obama who's quite a powerful orator sort
of a peaceful calm how would you
characterize the way that putin is
it's a very good question
i've never been asked that you know
it's very
different
from
other world leaders he's very articulate
in russian
even though he's kind of a simple guy
he's not like hyper educated and
he doesn't use sophisticated words
and
but there's a certain conviction in the
way he says things
which
the way russians
have been basically
we've been conditioned to look for the
strong man russia if you take out the 10
years of 1990 to 2000 we always had a
guy
okay that's a guy
they always
they don't need barack obama barack
obama would not last in russia bro
donald trump probably would but you see
where i'm going with this so he's much
closer to donald trump than barack obama
he's basically
he'll say what he's what he thinks and
he'll be very aggressive and he's not
going to play politically correct like
in his speech about the war he was
saying hey ukraine doesn't have a right
to exist it's run by a bunch of
drug addicts and neo-nazis and we're
going to take it back because ukraine is
not even a real country it's just a
bunch of idiots who are puppet
government blah blah blah
no world leader talks like that can you
imagine anybody
and that's
it's really tailor suited for the
russian audience
he's the hero that they're going to be
seduced by
yes
and also don't forget he controls all
the media internally like russian people
are not that exposed at least like
the older generation they don't expose
to reddit and [ __ ] so that's the news
they're getting
um all right so take me back we've got
that's the the situation at least when
the initial invasion occurred
run through some of the financial
sanctions that have happened and what
the impact has been on russia from there
well mainly the main thing they did is
look they they took individual banks off
of swift which is pretty much a death
sentence
to banks swift is basically a system
where banks
a unilate uni
unified
standardized system where banks can talk
to each other to transfer money
internationally
there's a i don't remember the full
words the
it's an it's it's a it's it's a belgian
system it's been adopted worldwide if
you take banks off of that system it's
pretty much
you're screwed
now they did that
and what mostly what was interesting is
they also went for the russian
national bank not just individuals they
went for the biggest banks in russia
not all of them but also they went for
the central bank when you say we went
for what you mean
they they basically took it off
partially from swift now here's the
thing
when they sanction the central bank and
they're saying nobody can touch that
nobody can work with this bank i mean
technically they can still transfer
money technically but nobody in the
right mind would do it because when you
have the us and the eu and the rest of
the world is literally everybody's
basically saying we're not we're not
dealing with you it's basically uh
they're taking away his war chest that
bank was the warchest that he built for
this so he created his central bank is
sitting
on
650 billion dollars
of cash
in dollars
uh in foreign currency various foreign
currencies uh some of it 130 billion is
in gold which is i mean here's to kip i
mean that that that money we can't touch
but everything else is foreign currency
it's dollars and euros and whatever it's
it's a mixture and
them taking away
about
500 out of the 640 billion and basically
saying hey you can't touch this
it's really limiting
um do what he can do because obviously
it's gonna it's gonna be a death
sentence to the economy for an idol for
an idiot like me who doesn't understand
how the financial markets work when you
say you can't touch this that's that's
i'm gonna guess that's technically not
right he he could touch it the point is
that it's only useful if he's then able
to trade it with a country that's
prepared to buy it and by being taken
off of swift the the uh function that he
was able to exchange that okay yeah yeah
so it's not like the money's gone but
the only function that the money has is
when it's in trade with another country
and because he can't do that because of
swift that's now being killed
it's the fact that the technicals are
not that important the factor is the
money is not usable which is the
important part and when the money is not
usable it's basically there's a war
machine that needs to be fed
and he doesn't have the finance to feed
it
and the problem is when you have that
look it's an expensive war
ukraine
isn't
you remember when he invaded to georgia
and not the state in the us he invaded
the country called georgia uh
it's it's it's it was a couple hundred
hundred thousand people it's ukraine
is one-third of the sides of russia
and russia is ginormous ukraine is a
massive country
like 30 40 million people
it's insanely
it's insanely huge i don't know if you
know how to explain to this and the
thing about ukraine is which is the
second part where i think he he
misunderestimated what's going on is
that
like with germany that basically came
out said you know what this has gone too
far
we're basically we dare you
not to send the gas to us because when
germany came out and said this they're
still they're still on the gas
to my knowledge there's not been any
interruptions in the provision of gas
because
germany is basically telling hey we call
your bluff
like you need this as much as we need
the gas because they need the money from
germany
they need the money when there's no war
40 of russian budget is digging [ __ ]
from the ground and selling it to other
people bro it's it's a ricky ass economy
with no modern [ __ ] bases it's just
the most unsophisticated economy in the
world bro so when
like
almost half of your economy is selling
energy
so i dare you they basically told them
we dare you not to send the guys to us
we there and he didn't it's still going
on so
they call this bluff more importantly
what he didn't actually take into
account is germany saying you know what
we're done being
we're done being like kumbaya on the
campfire we're gonna arm ourselves to
the teeth
and because this diplomatic diplomacy
thing isn't working with you you're
crazy
so
and again a certain amount of
circumstances happened
that he i don't think he understood when
angela merkel
stepped down
nobody really knew who all of schultz is
and what kind of guy he is apparently
he's the kind of guy that don't take no
[ __ ] from nobody bro because he just
came out on friday
and said hey
yeah we're going to spend 100 billion
euros this year on upgrading a military
and from now on going forward two
percent of our gdp which is insane bro
it's gonna go to military because
without the stick this diplomacy thing
is meaningless we just saw what you did
in ukraine so he basically created a
unification of nato
they're all on board right now he's
isolated and germany is basically
becoming a [ __ ] military superpower
which is exactly what he didn't want so
it's a gross miscalculation now the main
problem here
is
and that that boggles my mind how he
didn't think about it when ukraine
bro some of the toughest people i know
are ukrainians bro like these are people
i have ukrainian friends who can live a
whole week on the potato and the [ __ ]
egg bro like you don't you haven't seen
toughness until you've seen some
ukrainian like i'm not even exaggerating
bro these are tough people they live off
the land
you know what they did to the nazis bro
like they would they will hide in the
woods for 20 years and [ __ ] come and
stab you in the ass every day if you
talk about horrible guerrilla warfare
bro and like partisans like ukraine is
never going to [ __ ] be quiet bro this
is what so i said that i'd had that jake
hanrahan uh conflict reporter on
recently and he was telling me that one
of the problems that you have if russia
does end up taking let's say it takes
kiev right that then once you've managed
to stop moving forward it goes house to
house it goes guerrilla warfare it's you
don't know if the person that's walking
down the street with the overcoat on is
going to buy a bottle of milk or if he's
got an ak-47 under there and a molotov
most likely he has an ak-47 because they
[ __ ] gave those out like candy bro
can you imagine a country that
that's giving out ak-47s
you know come over to the town house
grab your ak-47 in a couple of magazines
yeah fighting side by side by side with
vasily lomachenko and alexander usyk
bro what about what about the
the brothers the the klitschko brothers
bro what are they doing i mean
they're literally on the [ __ ]
barricades bro with the other guys
did i see
i saw a a post on instagram earlier on
today saying that they'd shot some
people they were like oh yeah we killed
10 people today
there's probably a lot more violence
going on that we know of and probably
there's innocent people getting shot
because when you arm citizens with
ak-47s there's a lot of people who are
going to unnecessarily get hurt can you
try and decide i had this conversation
about ukraine obviously you've got
friends i'm going to guess that they're
still in russia maybe even some extended
family that are in russia
what's the atmosphere like in there
what's the sense
well there was a
russian cnbc was on today and
they had this lady talking to
a guy who's like a professional
born trader and [ __ ]
and he was basically saying you know
what
i think i'm going to have to look for a
new job as a [ __ ] santa claus because
this is gone it's like well that's once
a year says it's all figured out then he
pops out a bottle of
booze and he just drinks it on air it's
like this is over i mean it's now it's
comedic and it's kind of funny but i
mean it's really sad if you think about
it because
the vast majority of people who are
going to get hurt by this
are basically being held hostage if you
think about it it's just regular people
who want to go to work come home eat
lunch
[ __ ] their wife go to bed you know wake
up the next morning do the same [ __ ]
every day they don't i mean
i don't know a lot of russian people who
want
russia to be at war with ukraine it's
it's literally as crazy as
us going to war with canada it's
unthinkable to me
is the split there majority age do you
think are you going to have people that
are a little bit older that are probably
going to be more in support
no it's crazy like most uh
okay so
it's great so
older people they tell you oh we don't
want the war in ukraine but we support
putin
the older people they like they're in
love with him
and the younger people are like they're
basically like what the [ __ ] is this
the hell is going on bro
i mean look
there's definitely
there's this uh
theme that's i've seen a lot of pseudo
experts talk about it and they say well
what if canada
signed a treaty with china
for a strategic alliance and they put
nukes on the border with the us would us
not go to war with canada
i mean theoretically maybe
we don't know but
the fact is that we have a country
that's been talking about joining nato
there's it's not even in the cards yet
they don't have any nukes because they
gave their nukes up in 1994 by the way
for assurances by the west that they'll
protect them if russia ever invades we
saw how that played out so a country
with no nukes they're not a part of the
okay they want to join nato okay i get
it but
i totally i totally understand why
people are pissed off at this
it's like this is completely uncalled
for
it's it's just
senseless violence and i think
personally that there's a lot of
religious elements to this
i think that he's 70 years old or almost
70
and i think he has this fantasy of
of recreating whatever it was when he
was
the head of the kgb or whatever he was
he was a pro you said on your video that
to be a sar
you can't just have one country you need
to have a kingdom and right now he
doesn't have a kingdom
i would say based on
the videos that i've seen
it appears to be
one insult after another by nato pushing
forward doing things that they said that
they weren't going to do compromising on
promises that they previously made
and then this is
putin maybe the timing is right with
regards to the season with regards to
where the currencies are america's such
and so yeah yeah i get that
but
i don't know i
given what i know about
the
internals of his political movement it
kind of doesn't surprise me there was
going to come a point
where this was going to happen
but let me ask you a question chris
nato
if you look at the map from 1997 to
right now nato has definitely expanded
and they took a lot of his former
allies with them
but the question i want to ask of you is
one simple question okay nato is
expanding beyond
what was the original understandings
when the berlin wall fell
so they basically russia got basically
pushed aside and
there was a day you don't matter anymore
fine that happened and i understand the
insult
definitely understand the insult by
somebody who grew up in that system went
through the humiliation
became i think a taxi driver after that
and had to climb all the way back like
he used to be a taxi driver after the
collapse of the of the ussr so
so he experienced the brunt of it like
he was stationed in east berlin
like a
kgb blah blah blah
going up in the ranks and then
i understand that
but
assuming all of it is 100 true does this
give you the right to say well nato is
overexpending so i'm going to take this
sovereign country who does not do
anything offensive against me i'm gonna
take the sovereign country and i'm just
gonna grab it i'm gonna bombard [ __ ]
the living hell out of it i'm just gonna
take it because nato is over expanding
i mean i don't see the justification
here no me neither but i think
it's too simplistic the people that are
accusing putin of just being an idiot or
a madman or a psychopath the guy may be
aggressive in nature and he may be
prepared to do things where the
tolerances don't make sense for other
countries but you know step by step by
step
again i don't think that it's the right
thing to do obviously because i'm not a
psychopath but
i like that like it's
there is a logical progression that
we've gone through here right to get
russia as a country to the stage where
this has happened it's not as if it's
something that's just happened overnight
again the response isn't the way that it
it should have gone but it does seem to
me like the people that uh it's too
simplistic and too basic of an
explanation to say oh it's just no i
don't i don't think he's just doing it
because it is just he's just a
transformer
yeah yeah he's not a james bond villain
this is not a movie
this is not like ah
there's definitely
there's definitely um
yeah but also there's a very famous
researcher that passed away in the in
1989 barbara tuckman
she used to write a lot about political
science and geopolitics and global
politics
and she
the one of the main lines that you can
see throughout her her work is basically
she showed how
some of the most
influential critical decisions that were
made
on the global politics ring
was driven by emotional and policy of
responses by
people who were at a position of power
and she gives a lot of examples the most
amusing one
to me was her going back to the french
revolution
and basically well how did louis didn't
understand what was going on and
basically she said well he was he was
busy with trying to figure out if mary
antoinette was [ __ ] around with his
brother or not for the past two years
before the revolutions he was [ __ ]
psychopath a neurotic jealous husband so
he completely
missed the you know the doom the doomday
scenario but there's definitely a
mixture i think of everything here
there's definitely a strategic thinking
behind well
he wants to
clap back at nato
for sure
there's definitely i think him saying
i'm going to bring back the ussr at
least some sort of a quasi
strong
kind of uh
russia 2.0
and he's been very systematic with
getting it done by the way for all
intents and purposes belarus is no
longer even belarus it's just a name
so
he already has the guy in place to
replace uh uh
to replace zelinski
so
however
at the end of the day
and here's where i think
the problem lies
strategic yes
emotional somewhat for sure
but
if you and i would have thought before
that
given the balance of power with the with
the european energy consumption
would germany actually go all look full
on ham on him like they did
and [ __ ]
militarize and sanction like
i don't think anybody could have seen
germany pull that stunt on him i think
he was as surprised as most
analysts
what's happened in the u.s stock market
then how's that responded
to be honest somewhat okay so
oil price
i don't know if you follow the crude oil
but you don't give a [ __ ]
it's uh
so um we just came off of a
i think
usually like the prices in the 80s 80
per barrel it's tolerable
a hundred dollars per barrel is
considered like
oh
this is like a wartime pricing right
we're currently at like 111 112
so this happened real fast so oil prices
crude oil is going through the roof
commodities is going through the roof
obviously you know russia is you know
wheat palladium aluminium you name it
they they they dig [ __ ] from the ground
over there that's the whole that's the
whole business model right
uh
also what's happening in us is very
interesting
military contractors are flying high
raytheons the general dynamics all of
these are going flying high cyber
security is flying high fortinet
crowdstrike and even palantir had a
little bit of a of a upswing even though
they're kind of giving it back but i
think in general the u.s stock market
has been fine it had a little bit of a
of a kind of invasion day slump and then
it's basically
you know business as usual it's going up
jean-paul was on tv yesterday saying hey
we're only raising interest just a
little bit just a tiny bit just to feel
how it feels like and they basically
everybody said well good we're we so
i would say
largely on
unaffected but the thing is look as big
as russia is
the exposure of the sap 500 to the
russian economy honestly it's like 0.1
it doesn't do anything bro russia is
just they dig [ __ ] from the ground they
sell like energy and
and
resources there's not a technological
hub there's not a lot of russian
companies on nasdaq or the new stock
exchange there's just not a lot of
exposure in banking there is like
there's a few banks who have high
exposure to europe and russia but that's
pretty much it
what are you doing then so a lot of
messages i've had from friends over the
last week or so has been around
[ __ ] man what's going to happen with the
stock market i've got investments i've
got crypto i've got properties i've got
cash i've got gold
not trying to
capitalize from a wartime problem but
the the other way to look at this is
you play different people well yeah
precisely that people who
haven't done anything wrong you know
just some guy in the middle of america
who's been saving up and buying things
and trying to invest appropriately could
if the situation was responded to more
differently with the u.s stock market
could end up being wiped out by
something that's happening on the other
side of the planet so what's your
personal strategy or what would you say
to people around here are some things
that i would probably avoid over the
next however long here are some places
that i would keep an eye on etc
okay so there's two questions here and
they have completely different answers
so
the more interesting question
is crypto which you ask which is very
smart because whatever just happened
right now
is a second proof of the importance of
cryptocurrency just after what happened
in canada
so i'm not a big crypto guy
but i understand the importance of
having decentralized currency
when just you know just a little while
ago everybody was talking about canada
and the canadian regulation basically
allowing the government to
dip into people's banks accounts and
take money if they thought they were
related to the protest right
it's
it's crazy so proof number one then we
have
a couple of weeks go by now we have
proof number two right now
and again we're talking assuming we're
talking about law abiding tax paying
normal [ __ ] engineers who don't give
a [ __ ] about russia or ukraine but
they're stuck in [ __ ] russia and they
need a way to feed their family right
what do you have other than crypto bro
to do that right now the ruble is
basically deflating faster than the you
know a drunk man and a thailand [ __ ]
house
basically so it's worthless or it's
about to be so
if you ever needed a proof of concept of
how crypto plays a role in modern
economy in this chaotic world
you haven't you have it right now and
the main part is where people were
attacking crypto for the past few years
basically well it's not transactional
it's not exactly it's not
i mean you can't go to a grocery store
and pay with bitcoin
it's it's really complicated the fees
are expensive it takes time it's
complicated it's not built for
transactions well some do like
there's certain not bitcoin there's more
kind of i'm not gonna
uh promote any here but there's more
transactional cryptocurrencies but we're
talking about bitcoin which is kind of
the gold standard because bitcoin
doesn't need me to advertise bitcoin
come on
but all i'm saying is like
proof of concept of why it's important
you just saw it like
russian government literally telling
their people hey [ __ ] 80 of
your cash converted to rubles right now
or foreign currency right if you have
bitcoin
i mean that's the perfect example of
they can touch you and that's kind of
the proof of why you want to hold it in
the wallet and not in a proxy you know
through a through a brokerage because
i've been having this debate with people
and it's like when is the government
ever going to force where you go in
canada here go in russia okay so that
part is true so cryptocurrency just got
a big boost and that's why i think it's
running up because people are seeing
okay this makes sense
as far as how to play defense in the
market again
i
i don't have any understanding in day
trading or swing trading it's not my
expertise i don't understand nothing in
it i'm a long term investor most of the
companies i invested in my portfolio is
very narrow talent here tesla google s p
500 that's the only stock i have in my
portfolio
as a long-term investor
all i suggest you do is just [ __ ]
chill the [ __ ] down
just go watch some porn take a walk
outside take a hike drink some coffee
just relax bro because
the only thing you need to do chris is
just pull out the not what you think
pull out the s p 500
and expand it
to a ten year period or a five year or
whatever
you will see that no matter how much
[ __ ] has been going on in the world and
believe me the past 10 years there's
been a lot of [ __ ] going on in the world
people forget we had the 2008 crash in
the us
we had so much gnarly stuff going on in
the world the s p 500 which is the u.s
stock market u.s economy always going up
long term if you're a long-term investor
you literally don't give a [ __ ] about
short-term volatility
so
i i
playing around with your portfolio too
much first of all you're creating tax
disadvantages at least in the us now
you're in the us you should know this
you're creating short-term capital gains
if you trade
if you trade in and out of a stock
under a year you just you just almost
double your tax liability and completely
killed your alpha
so that's there's that
now beyond the fact beyond the tax
issues
of course unless you have it in the ira
or 401 never mind but beyond the tax
issues
it's been statistically proven that
there's a correlation between how much
more you're active
and how much more losses you get
no no no there's literally a stat i have
to find it somewhere so the s p 500 went
up for the past 10 years like crazy
right you can pull up the chart
eighty-five percent of people who wars
in the s p 500 lost money only about 15
make money most people lose money in the
stock market long term even though it
always goes up because most people are
impatient warren buffett literally said
this said the stock market
is a wealth transfer mechanism from the
inpatient to the patient
so the worst thing you can do is fiddle
around with your portfolio and try to
time the market just
again if you're a swing trader if you're
a professional day trader i don't that's
the whole different enchilada i don't
understand nothing as the long term if
your friends are long-term investors
just you know
unless you pick garbage stock which
which is it
it's a it's a whole different discussion
that you might have to you know fix your
portfolio but if you have solid
conviction and you think you you went
for winners
what does the war in ukraine change
really bro okay
energy is going to be more expensive for
a while probably
inflation is only going to make it worse
sure but it's across the field
everybody's it's like playing soccer
when it's raining or snowing everybody's
in the same [ __ ] pitch it doesn't
really matter have you got any insight
around people that are holding cash or
real estate
well
i'm not a real estate guy but
the one asset that's been
overperforming the market and i'll tell
you why it's kind of an easy answer is
real estate real estate again
real estate has been basically
the
best safe harbor
like when you have inflation what's the
one thing you want to do you want to
hold assets not cash right so cash real
estate they're kind of
they're the opposite sides of the same
story right in low inflation you want
more cash in high inflation you want
more assets because if you have a home
it's worth whatever it is it's worth so
you don't need to be worried about
inflation the problem is with real
estate that's what happened over the
past two years is again you you're on
the ground you've seen this happen
the prices of real estate because
everybody understands this simple
concept right the prices have lost all
like
bro justin i was talking he just sold
this like
it's just
it gotten so bad it literally killed
open door and zillow bro
because people like
it's the apps where you sell your house
online with the open door with chamath
sparky like zillow like people like we
don't need no help selling our house bro
there's no need no look it's like we can
double our money right now so
everybody's rushing towards real estate
so it becomes very dangerous
like you just need to be careful again
you're probably more of a real estate
guy than me but conceptually i would
just be you know
not trying to park my money unless they
can get a good deal and getting good
deal nursery right now in the u.s is
very tough
it's the same in the uk uk markets on
fire at the moment there was
one of my buddies just sent me
a stat around right move which is our
equivalent of you might even have it it
might work out here in america
and it had its busiest day ever
ever the most number of new properties
and the highest volume of traffic not
long ago yeah
why and it's not like inflation is going
away chris i mean we're at seven and a
half right now
if energy prices keeps going up
inflation is not gonna come down it's
simple because what do you need to make
everything
energy energy
energy is more expensive
there you go
simple not to mention the fact that
you've pumped in five and a half
trillion dollars into the system that
somehow it's like eating five trays of
pizza bro you have to [ __ ] it out before
you can go for a run i mean it's that
simple bro
what do you think is going to happen in
the medium to long term then
well that's a that's a great question
if
assuming that look the us has i can only
talk about the us
the u.s has an inflation problem that is
kind of the perfect storm
whenever you have a really bad situation
it's a combination of of
you know i always give the example of
the nuclear disaster in chernobyl
like it was such an improbable event so
much had to go wrong in the same
sequence for the [ __ ] to happen but when
it does it's catastrophic okay so the
u.s inflation problem is literally a
combination of things that are
what are the odds well there you go
those are the odds this just happened
like
morphe murphy's law bro so the u.s
problem is number one obviously they
printed a lot of money
every kid knows that that's the easy
part
so
there's supply chain shortages
okay where people were more at home and
now you have
you have issues with basically the
trucking industry the logistic like
it's not easy right now getting people
out of out of their homes it started
with culvert but now people are
basically saying well i can just [ __ ]
do affiliate marketing from home and
make more money right why would i go
drive a truck not be around my family
for three weeks right so
you have to pay more to attract drivers
or
people who work in the logistical
industry so you pay more obviously it's
inflation so
um
and you have zero rate interest which
means
everybody's spending if you have zero
interest why would you hold your money
in the bank there's no point in saving
money zero percent interest so
everybody's spending so a lot of money
in the system crazy spending logistical
hardships and on top of it the us now
has to face what they've neglected for
the past 30 years there's a major
problem on the west coast
where all the goods from china or not
all
a lot of
a lot of the goods from china are coming
in from two ports which is long beach
and l.a and those two ports
when it was
when it wasn't as crazy as now it kind
of held its own somewhat it was you know
like uh
it was up there it was a little bit
tough but they they they held their own
but now when basically we have the city
where they don't have the employees why
they don't they literally bro they've
literally not been sending
crates and uh and containers back to
china because they don't have the
manpower or the time to load it back on
the ships going back which has created
an insane cost to
containers which is exaggerating the
problem so
the us has to fix the [ __ ]
infrastructure as far as the port system
goes as far as the trucking industry
there's like look
think of it this way on top of this
this all the situation that just
described to you if you could just raise
interest rates you would have probably
alleviated a lot of the problem if the
government would say hey listen
like they did this in the 80s there was
a fed chair his name was paul walker and
he did this in the 80s he said look 15
interest right now
that's a that's a major it's like
pulling the handbrake when you're going
on the freeway bro so you might crash
well you're probably going to crash but
you're going to stop for sure the
problem is
when paul volcker did this we didn't
have
a u.s debt the size of our gdp we
literally have 100
size of u.s national debt compared to
gdp
so we are servicing a lot of debt
so every percentage point we raise
on the interest to slow down the market
is going to cost
270 billion dollars give or take a few a
few dollars so
right why is the fed now saying oh okay
just point 25
because they literally can't afford to
do more and when they say can't afford
it they can always print more money but
what happens if you print more money to
service the debt you're basically just
creating more cash in the system
basically making inflation worse so
there's they have to figure out
and there's long theories on how you can
get this done because
you can create you can roll over a lot
of
it's getting boring so i'll do it quick
the u.s it's like when you know when you
take a mortgage and you go to the bank
right and they tell okay what kind of
mix you want
and you say well i don't want to put
everything on just fixed it's going to
be expensive right give me like half and
half right
i'll take half fixed and half variable
because the variable is [ __ ] cheap so
this is what the us government has been
doing and that that was okay
but now half or i think more than half
of their u.s national debt is basically
dependent on interest rates so they're
super sensitive to interest rates so
they can pretty much say hey we're just
going over to we're rolling over a big
chunk of our national debt to 30 years
which is fixed
and then we're going to pay a little
penalty like 300 400 million billion
sorry 3 400 because that's the
difference i think it's like
one and a half percent difference or two
percent so we're going to take the
penalty we'll pay the 400 billion
whatever it is but we're going to stop
any concerns of interest rates then we
don't give a [ __ ] and we can raise
interest rates and fix this this would
be one solution
it has its problems the other solution
would be to outgrow gdp
out of the debt which basically means
reducing taxes deregulating everything
let the economy go boom
but
there's political issues with doing that
i mean a democratic government lowering
taxes doesn't really work so they're
stuck in this limbo so the fed and the
government need to figure out a way to
work together until the government
provides
a viability for the fed to raise
interest rates the fed is going to
basically be stuck saying well we've
decided not to raise interest rates
because they can't they literally are
are jammed until the government does
something about the debt so that's kind
of my little quick primer about what's
going on with inflation it seems [ __ ]
uh in you know what alternative
explanation we are [ __ ] this seems
dude
they'll figure it out dude look we paid
them
to figure it out we pay them to sleep at
night and not worry about these things
let them worry about the aliens and the
the national debt and all the stuff we
don't want to know bro what are you
worried about then if you're not worried
about the inflation and stuff like that
i'm worried about being a good dad man
that's the only thing i'm concerned
about
do you have to figure it out
yes
what do you struggle with i have high
standards of myself
i'll give an example so my my dad he was
a cool dude but he was a little bit of
an absentee dad not in that bad sense he
was just working a lot you know what i
mean he was a good dude always like no
issues i love them and i love him he's
still life i mean we have a good
relationship you can always give him a
call but i mean we didn't do jack [ __ ]
together ever because it was always
working
that's why initially i quit my job
basically i said i'm not going to be
that guy
so
i my my midlife crisis when i hit 40 was
basically quitting my job and basically
being like more of a dad now it's gotten
to a point where i'm so [ __ ] critical
of myself
so
my wife was away for two days and i was
along with the three kids on my own and
i had to organize them in the morning to
go to school and the first day it was a
complete it was like putin invading
ukraine bro it was
screaming at them they're [ __ ] crying
it's like
getting to school late they're all
[ __ ] like i the whole day i'm sitting
in the corner [ __ ] shaking how the
[ __ ] did i just
[ __ ] ruin this [ __ ] morning like
and like they forgot about it in 20
minutes but i'm like my whole day is
[ __ ] gone to [ __ ] bro i was like how
how [ __ ] like
and then i made the decision i said okay
so we have two more days i'm gonna make
it like as magical as possible i'm gonna
be like not the perfect dad but i'm
gonna i'm not gonna [ __ ] let it
happen again and then the next days bro
i'm i kid you look i like people like oh
volunteer is down 12 like [ __ ] i
just had the best two days with my kids
bro it was all [ __ ] clockwork nobody
everybody's happy took them out for ice
cream mornings were like everything was
[ __ ]
literally split i was like you're like
oh tom are you not concerned about no
[ __ ] that's the thing that i'm
obsessing about that's where i'm at
right now in my life uh i couldn't give
less fox
dude i have a bunch of friends who are
unbelievable high achievers athletes
coaches businessmen
and the thing that they struggle with is
their
ability to be a dad
it's tough
so i'm not i'm not a dad at least not
one that i know uh and
um
but i can't i can't wait to be one but
the test is the most
it's the most exhilarating feeling ever
but when you fail at that
occasionally
it's so crushing bro
high stakes like
and sometimes they ask you the craziest
[ __ ] like my
six-year-old asked me
uh it's like how do how do a boy and a
girl create a baby
or my older one is like
why do we how do we know that god isn't
black
they ask you the crazy [ __ ] i don't know
like i don't know like what
it's like they'll come out with some
crazy ass and my my four-year-old
son
he has a photographic memory bro don't
forget jack [ __ ]
so he would come out hey two weeks ago
you promised me this and this and that
i've been waiting for two weeks where
the [ __ ] is this and he's four bro and
he doesn't forget if you tell him so
it's
it's it's it's
it's a tough gig bro but when you hit it
right it's like hitting that homework
it's like it's better than sex but when
you hit it right when you have like a
perfect day
this is the best feeling ever bro what
do you need to work on then if you were
to look at your stats patience
that's the answer that every guy that i
know gives
yeah man
when you lose it it's too late
you can't bring it back you know what i
mean
because kids they don't grasp it as like
oh i [ __ ] up so that is pissed off
they're like oh that is screaming at me
angry dad you know what i mean you're
the meme
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't even
remember what they did wrong
it's like
i'm not comparing kids to dogs
by no means but if you have a dog like
you don't he doesn't understand
sometimes like why are you angry you
know what i mean
they just
they'll do some bro i'll give an example
like the day that it all fell apart for
me it's like when they see you
struggling they'll push harder to try to
break you
so
we're on bro we're ready like everything
is went to [ __ ] we're at the door
my youngest is trying to get into the
elevator himself which is a [ __ ] it's
a life-threatening situation so i'm
trying to get him
my oldest is in the house refusing to
come out and my my middle one is
basically standing at the door and i'm
asking her is this your jacket i'm not
sure my wife usually knows she says no
and then my oldest one is screaming yes
it's her jacket like is this yours said
no no she's lying to you like the kid is
trying to get in the elevator he's like
what is going on
like they're testing me bro like
so i i eventually i was about i took the
jackets like i'm going to put this in
the trash until you tell or you tell me
when i said this i was like at this
moment you know at this moment he knew
he [ __ ] up i was like oh
[ __ ] got me
and the crying and everything but the
next two days bro i killed it i [ __ ]
killed it out of the [ __ ] park
everything was pop bro i even like the
second day
i decided i'll i'll order pizza for them
which they love but i i [ __ ] with them
i told them that everything we're having
for dinner is just [ __ ] vegetables so
they [ __ ] filled up with a shitload
of vegetables and then i [ __ ] i
ordered the pizza after that pizza on
them after that
good yeah i was like that's that's dad
triple a bro it's like a homer bro when
you do something you're impressed about
the fact that you managed to outwit
three tiny idiots
they're smart they're combined their
combined age is less than half of yours
and you manage to outwit them and you're
somehow feeling satisfied about that you
know how savvy kids are with reading you
like for example if you read them a book
they can feel if you're impatient if you
just want to get it out of there and
leave
like the bedtime story they can feel
everything
their
emotional uh
quantity
is far better than grown-ups give them
credit for they understand everything
they're very smart
all kids not just men you need a
spreadsheet you need a spreadsheet so
that you can track them oh man
it's it's going to be the most
complicated spreadsheet in humanity
trust me bro
you have it like it's going to look like
the
the john nash you know the scribblings
on the wall and [ __ ] the beautiful
mind bro it's gonna be something of that
level catastrophic
that's where it needs to be man yeah i'm
looking forward to you know whenever
whenever it finally happens i really am
excited about the prospect of becoming a
dad one thing i think about a lot is the
um
intensity of emotions
that you're going to have you know it's
the first time you're going to touch
something which is because of you you
know a living thing
which is because of you and it doesn't
surprise me that you see you know
there's videos on the internet and
they're funny or whatever of parents
going like full helicopter parents no
plan parent [ __ ] but i kind of
understand the compulsion of where that
comes from that you have this tiny
creature that you've brought into the
world and you're terrified of it being
hurt or injured or or upset or whatever
and your solution is to just knock
everything in terms of challenges or
discomfort out of their way uh and yeah
you know
it's going to be the most intense
emotions i've ever felt in my entire
life and i don't know i don't know how
i'm going to deal with that no you do
you do you'll be fine and the more you
have
the more you will find out that you had
a lot of uh secret unemployment before
in your life so you'll have one it's
like oh i had so much time before in my
life and then you have the second i said
oh [ __ ] well then only one i had so much
and then the more you add the more you
realize you had more freedoms when you
have three bro i don't know what it
feels like to have more but when you
have free i was like oh this is this is
like video game leveling up it never
gets easier you know they just the
problems get bigger they get more
crazier it's just
it's a guitar hero [ __ ] you know
ultimate mode it's like [ __ ]
it's crazy bro what are you doing next
then what are you working on either
personally or on the channel or is it is
dad mode and improving yourself as a dad
is that one of the priorities that's
that's the only priority but what i'm
doing as far as content is actually i'm
doing a new show with justin
uh we're doing a show called money talks
it's a daily show
half an hour every day 5 p.m
where we go at each other's throat it's
very different from the podcast you were
on
it's basically i don't know if you watch
sports
at all but it's kind of undisputed or
first take but for for stock market and
financials so we'll pick a few topics
and we'll just basically i'll destroy
them
simple
[Music]
i'll go to store and i [ __ ] kill him
bro
and uh yeah that's been a lot of fun and
uh
i just you know i don't have
like people ask me tom what if this
whole youtube thing is gone tomorrow i
honestly don't care because i leave so
much below my means
and i don't need really nothing
i haven't been splurging or spending at
all bro not because i'm cheap because i
don't need nothing to be honest
i i've been making a [ __ ] out of money
from youtube i live in the same
apartment drive the same car i haven't
bought any expensive jewelry i literally
done nothing with my money talk to me so
i i found this fascinating
every time that i speak to finance guys
they seem to fall into one of two
brackets one of them is the earn high
spend high
and the other one is sort of earn
appropriate spend low and that's the
morgan that's the morgan household thing
that money is the ability to do what you
want when you want with who you want for
as long as you want and no one can tell
you otherwise but the only way that you
can win at the game of finance is to
stop moving the goal posts every time
that you decide that you're going to
make an amount of money and then once
you've made that amount of money you
decide to either spend it or up your
liabilities to the stage where you've
now reset that's you can't put the ball
into the goal if the goal continues to
move away from you every time you get
closer to it
it's the recipe to being unhappy man
what you just described it's literally
the recipe it's uh
there's a name for this spencer coin i
told me this it did he didn't invent it
but there's
i forgot the name not hedonic adaptation
yes thank you
i feel like i just sneezed thank you so
satisfying when that happened dude i was
walking i was walking down the street
the other day with my buddy in austin
and i was trying to remember this guy's
name and then he caught on to who it was
that we were trying to remember and we
were walking to a smoothie bar and both
of us were walking down the street like
hitting our heads like shaking what the
[ __ ] is this yeah someone driving past
must have thought what the actual [ __ ]
are those two people doing like having a
psychotic episode as i'm walking down
the street desperately trying to
remember this dude's name and then one
of us got it and it was like someone had
just won the lottery like [ __ ] yes
yes
yes
it's cathartic when you when you have
that moment so thank you for that yeah
thank you you just gave me that good uh
look the thing is
have you ever bought something that you
never thought you would be able to
afford
a house
okay well a house is a utilitarian thing
but even the house actually fits into
this okay
let's say that you buy a [ __ ] three
million dollar mansion okay
for the first two weeks you're gonna be
like oh [ __ ] the pool and the [ __ ]
gym and the [ __ ]
bro week three you don't even give a
[ __ ] anymore it's just a house bro
it just it has zero
uh added value to your happiness you had
it for two weeks
and it's the same thing bro you can go
all the way up to helicopters [ __ ]
yacht
it will always be the first two weeks
you're gonna be [ __ ] [ __ ] over it
and then you don't give a [ __ ] anymore
it's just a thing
okay
so there's no point in chasing [ __ ]
happiness through things
it sucks being broke
and i guarantee you that your
relationship will suffer if you're
[ __ ] broke and you can't [ __ ]
provide for your family but as long as
you're not broke and you can provide for
your family everything else is [ __ ]
not necessary bro i can like people ask
me tom why don't you [ __ ] sell the
course i mean uh kevin sells of course a
thousand bucks a pop and he makes like
what two three million a month bro i
don't even know how much you make like i
could do that probably and probably i
can do a good course which people will
like and not hate me for but like why
i'd be basically
chasing something i don't need
and adding more responsibility on me
like
i find it really enjoyable just to come
online and [ __ ]
rant about [ __ ] and have zero
accountability responsibility bro do you
not think that the information that
you've got and the insights that you
could give people would be able to help
them make more money make better
financial decisions in their life
good question and i'll tell you yes but
still it's it's very dangerous
you remember the backlash that meet
kevin got
when he sold in so mid kevin the guy who
has like what 1.8 million subscribers in
finance and uh
[Music]
he said oh um
he sells a course for expensive course
and he said yeah i
i'm not there was a big dip in tech
stocks were dropping and he's like yeah
i'm not selling by the dip you weak
paper hands blah blah blah blah comes
out the next day i sold everything
so people are like what the [ __ ] kevin i
mean
so they come out and say what what the
[ __ ] is your course is what's the value
of the course if you basically do things
in the women or on the hunch it's
complete and there's no no there's a
methodology behind it it's like yeah
so basically i had him on my show and i
told it to his face i wouldn't have said
the story
if i didn't i had it on my show and i
interviewed him and said listen kevin i
mean i mean i don't think
i think it devalues significantly of
course
so i would be saying this behind his
back he knows i said this to him
when i don't sell a course i can do
whatever the [ __ ] i want bro i have zero
responsibility and accountability to
people i don't want to have that on my
back saying oh tom you taught me this
skill and for the past six months and
i'm gonna be have to i'm gonna be
explaining well look the market is like
it's like being employee again i have to
explain myself why you're not doing that
well bro i just make funny videos about
finance and geopolitics and some people
love them some people hate them
and i get paid just enough to have a
comfortable lifestyle bro i don't drive
a ferrari i don't have a [ __ ] tesla a
very simple european car very simple
apartment that's all i [ __ ] need bro
i don't need more
so i think that it i understand the
aversion to pressure right i understand
the fact that you're going to become
accountable to the people that buy the
course for the outcomes they get from
the course you're going to feel this
sense of obligation to stick to the
principles that you've come up with as a
part of the course i understand all of
that um i do think the particular sort
of audience that you've cultivated i
think that they would be very
understanding i think that you're quite
open about the fact that you've got
these failings and stuff and
i heard so much of them
yeah yeah very very public fuck-ups i
have the worst shooting percentage in
like i'm like russell westbrook from the
three bro i can't make it three yeah
the shittiest financial advisor in
history yeah but here's the thing like i
i think that
i i think that there's an argument to be
made that if you have an audience that
will listen to you that you know that
you can add value to
uh i don't think that you should look at
it as a purely sort of ruthless
capitalistic taking advantage of my
audience and stuff and maybe maybe
the price that you have to pay for
adding the maximum amount of value that
you can to your audience is the
accountability of the audience maybe
that's a duty that you have to them
maybe the fact that you're going to get
people saying well tom i tried your
course for this time and this thing
didn't come off and blah blah maybe if
you have a if 60 of the people that do
the course come out being better off
maybe the price that you have to pay is
the fact that you're going to have to
answer some uncomfortable messages
you know what if i ever do it
if i ever do it i'm going to offer
lifetime refunds that's for sure
like but then again it doesn't really
cover full like
bro if if if i refund somebody and they
lost a [ __ ] ton of money it's not gonna
[ __ ] help their feeling you know what
i mean
whatever like
you are right
it's different
uh creating a course about whatever how
to invest or how to operate your
finances what's the worst thing you can
happen if you teach me how to [ __ ]
game right i get a few notes precisely
like it's different to making a morning
routine or a productivity or something
like that yeah this is the fundamental
currency that people run their lives
with so i understand
think about it this way chris how many
people will even though you tell them
you tell them hey like i said this in my
videos all the time i said
the only money that should be in the
stock market is money you can afford to
lose shouldn't be your rent money kids
college money none of that [ __ ] only
play money
and still people will [ __ ] go yolo
into [ __ ] amc and jimmy bro and
they're gonna be like hey tom i did it
that's like
[ __ ] bro
so i had the guy i won't forget this bro
crazy ass british guy
who yellowed into gme
and
dude has
such a cool guy
made 1.4 million dollars
he went on leverage for he had no money
to even invest in jimmy wrote the whole
thing up
and i [ __ ] told him sell sales we had
the private conversation and i said look
zelda's just [ __ ] his dad is working
[ __ ] uh remote like in a different
country it's like the cell man
didn't sell bro
he only took out enough money to buy a
mercedes like a small like class a some
[ __ ] like this and like yeah he stayed
in and you know you know what happened
people won't listen to you
and then they'll blame you for not
listening to you or they'll listen to
you and they'll blame you for listening
to you there's it's like being a
goalkeeper bro when you're still a
course it's really tough now if you
don't give a [ __ ]
and you say well i'm going to take my
money and
hate is going to be hating fine i just
i have the the
prerogative to say hey haters be hating
if i don't sell nothing bro and people
like oh tom you have pete yeah well [ __ ]
off [ __ ] with your [ __ ] yeah
i have patreon bro all my content is
free
suck my dick [ __ ] paid kim bro nfts
yeah
that's what you need to do
i thought about it so scandal
[ __ ]
out of yourself
it's such a [ __ ] crazy
bro nfts
is what the internet was in the late 90s
well in the late 90s people thought that
internet was just for porn
[Laughter]
people think that the blockchain is just
for nfcs at the moment yeah and they
think that nfd is just this little
[ __ ] you know monkeys or whatever the
[ __ ] that they don't understand the
potential of the technology bro nfts
when they think it's just this little
art projects you haven't made it until
coffeezilla's done a video on you once
coffee's done a video on you
that's that's when i know that tom has
fully [ __ ] reached apogee yeah in
terms of
how are you going to get to
he's killing it bro
yeah
he's one of my favorite [ __ ] him
you
phillian spencer i i could watch barely
sociable
i i could watch this [ __ ] all day all
day
you know who i watch and i enjoy his
videos even though you there's a guy his
name is bold and bankrupt
this is a guy who basically and bankrupt
bold and bankrupt
so
he's he's kind of i mean he's my age so
he's old
so
he just he grabs a gopro and he goes to
these [ __ ] crazy places
like lately he's been geeking over
eastern europe just looking for like
he'll go to some
post soviet village where he can find
like a mosaic in the city square that's
from the ussr
he'll like get into people's houses and
[ __ ] drink illegal booze with them
like in russia like crazy like you have
to so is it is it vlogs it's kind of
like vlogs yes but it's like bro
i can't explain to you why it works it's
like when i i say vlogs you're like
i say irl like
i real vlogs
no but his is actually it's very good
i i can't explain it it's uh
it's it's it's brilliant who else do you
watch
uh i watch his stuff a lot
um
i'm i'm gonna be honest with you
sometimes i watch drama alert
oh yeah [ __ ] didn't you tell me didn't
you tell me that they were getting
involved in
this russian [ __ ] yeah they made it
they made a video called russia
cancelled
i love keemstar
he has such a
nice way of serving you a burger when
you just want a burger you know what i
mean
i love that the here's the burger
i watch a channel called mustard nobody
has heard of it mustard is the
engineering channel so he'll break down
like create like it's for super geeks
like uh
warships from world war ii and how they
were i'm a fan of i'm a fan of stuff
like that
so it's called mustard m-u-s-d-a-r-d
he breaks down all trains and what's
what's brilliant about this channel the
narration is amazing research is amazing
he makes the most beautiful 3d models of
the old stuff he's talking about that
don't exist anymore he almost kind of
brings them back to life
like he did a whole video about the
buran the brand was supposed to be a
soviet uh version of the uh
of of the space shuttle
it was never it was never it was almost
and so he brought it back to life or he
he brings [ __ ] back to life that don't
exist anymore and it's it's just it's
just so beautiful bro
it's almost it's as pleasing visually as
it is to hear about the stuff like he
did a whole video about the shinkansen
and how like the origins the japanese
bullet train and how it started out how
it was complete failure and like crazy
ship really good channel you you'd love
this channel i'm telling you right now
it's wild some of the ones that go and
do this unbelievable deep dive
are
just insane like do go go that does um
i remember that i forget the channel's
name anyway like this australian dude
who does these unbelievable jake tran
bro jake tran does
phenomenal
documentary level videos three days a
week
just i don't know how
well he's got i think he's got a big
editing team that's below him now but
still like to research his the
production is mostly his the recording's
all his and he was still putting that
out when he first started this is this
channel called melody sheep have you
heard of that no oh man it is so many
talented people
so melody sheep's
wild they do one video about every two
years
and they yeah it's [ __ ] crazy so they
did one called life beyond earth which
is a three-part documentary series the
entire thing is 3d rendered in
computer generated imagery and it takes
you through
the different ways that life could
evolve on other planets let's say that
this planet has really dense air let's
say that this planet is completely
gaseous let's see what happens if we
take away carbon-based life forms and we
create silicon-based life forms where
the metabolisms are so low that they
could live for millions and millions of
years and their thought cycles would be
you know the the amount of time it takes
a human a a star to live and die would
be one thought from them because that's
how slowly that they would exist melody
sheep three-part series called life
beyond earth
outrageous it's so good the whole
thing's soundscaped beautifully
engineered gorgeous voiceovers and the
visuals and the whole thing's in 4k they
i remember seeing so how do they make
money with so scarce i have no i think
they might have a patreon or something
but these guys they they have to be
professionals there's no way that you
could produce something like this and
not be
working for netflix on the side or some
[ __ ] but then maybe not maybe they are
just some bros look at james johnny bro
james johnny makes netflix level
documentaries i'm not familiar with him
james johnny
oh he's a really cool guy he's a
he makes these unbelievable
documentaries about
money marketing um
yeah darkish kind of uh nice
yeah very good very good creator
yeah oh okay as well okay eyes weird
stories is
fantastic it's kind of like jake tran
but for bizarre dark nets
stories yeah you you oh i think i've
stumbled upon this this is actually a
very oh
k
i at the beginning this japanese girl
does it yeah it's a
it's awesome man there really is some
like youtube at the moment
if you get the right algorithm moving my
news feed on not not the chris
williamson channel that all this stuff
goes out on because that's just research
and me doing all sorts of mad stuff but
on my personal one it's
just endless like all of the stuff
that's on my suggested feed i want to
watch the say what you want about
youtube dude that algorithm suggests
fire all the time it's always good [ __ ]
that i want to watch
i agree i agree to that
compare it to what youtube used to be
when it was just your subscription feed
the amount of trash you would like i
can't believe i'm still subscribed to
that
i'm sure people say that about my
channel i'm sure yeah is that guy still
going that russian guy surely
he's dead
chris
before
you let me go to sleep because
i told you i'm not in 100
i want to ask your opinion about
something
so you're kind of a student of the game
and not that kind of game
but do you think there's a way
psychologically speaking because you
don't know the guy that
[Music]
putin actually can
not
uh demolish everything around him and
just go back home and said well this was
not a good idea i fear that his ego
would not allow him to do it anymore
i think based on what very little i know
about the man i would say
that seems incredibly unlikely uh it's a
huge embarrassment on the world stage it
would involve
everybody
mocking russia as a global power for a
very very long time it would mean that
everybody else would feel like
maybe he called our bluff but he wasn't
actually holding the cards in his hand
that he said he was so he's going to
start to be bullied i mean the sanctions
that he gets long-term let's say that he
does decide to turn around and go back
to russia okay so you've suffered the
russian people have got all of these
problems the ruble's gone through the
floor you can't use swift you've spent
all of this money you've lost all of
these soldiers you've lost all of this
military hardware and for what
you know so there's a um
a gambler's fallacy thing here uh that's
that's going on a little bit uh there's
a
sunk cost fallacy that's going on
there's the fact that there's the ego
there's the fact that the russian people
at least for the most part are behind
him again there's another problem that
you have here that the when the state
media is pushing the narrative that you
want to hear the russian people in no
way are going to be prepared for you to
then renege on what you were doing
because they've never heard another side
of the story there's no
i'm sure that the russian media is
showing absolutely zero potential that
russia can even lose this look at how
well we're doing look at the
progress that we're making on all fronts
and blah blah blah so no one's prepared
for it it would be an embarrassment
domestically and internationally
in terms of his ego i don't think it
would i
i don't think that i think he get the
only way that that would happen that he
would turn around and go home is if he's
losing so much men or financially it
becomes untenable to continue moving
forward to the point where but that's
not even going to be a retreat that's
just going to
fizzle out very very slowly and then
just die of death
if you're right
it means
very bad things for ukraine because it
means that
you will have to turn up the heat
you mean in terms of military hardware
like bigger bombs
bigger bombs
less
strategic bombing more kind of
just basically indiscriminate
yeah
this is going to be
horrific if this happens what do you
think what's your prediction
look i honestly don't know but i feel
like if they
give him 60 of what he wants
they might get a deal done well chop
chop ukraine in half
no well
he has to accept
current government stays
and the
the west will have to accept no nato
ever for ukraine and the bits already
chopped off he gets to keep
this deal can be probably worked out
but i feel like
if you're putting you don't take this
deal unless you think you're gonna lose
and i don't know if
he thinks that he's gonna lose because
these dictators they tend to be detached
you know what i mean chris are these
peace talks just bollocks then because
i'm hearing that there's peace talks
proposed for this day and this day and
this day yeah and apparently the last
time they had peace talks last week
putin just used that as an opportunity
to rotate his troops
yeah
everybody's saying that it's garbage
this is just garbage time
i don't know but i think if they if
if a deal can be made it probably is
within those boundaries of what i said
because everything else
is going to be undoable for for
for either party
let's pray they can find a way to
get a deal done because if they can't
look
can you imagine like people who like
kids going to school just a week ago
and [ __ ] imagine bombs [ __ ]
falling in your neighborhood
just even if nothing happens to you what
it does to your sidekeeper
they post trauma
just even without casualty
this is horrific bro
i pray that it ends i don't want more at
all
and there's people that were milkman
last week you know your local postman
and milkman
are now holding ak-47s stood side by
side with alexander yousig trying to
stop an invading force it's wild it's
absolutely wild and i think you know the
one one of the few positives that i
think that you can draw from it is that
it reminded everybody
there was a presumption i think
especially amongst young people
millennials that because we haven't seen
any conflict in our lifetime that we we
kind of were in post history we got past
the potential for war
oh look we've managed to create peace
through
a combination of deterrence and um
like nice agreements uh and superpowers
and super pacs that grow who bind
countries together yeah
and it's reminded everybody that you
can't have boots on the ground and guns
in hands and um
yeah maybe it's given a wake-up call to
a lot of people that thought it was all
sweetness and the same way as
kovitz dude you know i think things have
been always [ __ ] up
it's just now it's happening in europe
and it's people like oh close to home
it's been happening like for for for the
last 30-40 years
it's somewhere else so you're like oh
yeah whatever like those like now it's
happening
next to the doorstep and now it's
[ __ ] scary
so
i feel i feel like uh
we should pray that this [ __ ] doesn't
get out of hand because we're one spit
away from some horrific [ __ ] bro
this is like
can you believe it
bro
here was something that was talking
about yesterday that
there's kind of people are happy to talk
about mental health and and say you know
it's okay to not be okay
reach out and talk to a friend if you're
depressed stuff like that but it's
supposed to be there's still an element
that that's supposed to be for serious
stuff you know my parents have just died
or i've become homeless or i've lost my
job or i've done whatever
the last think about the last three
years ish
of experience for most people on the
planet it's been this just
constant ambient anxiety concern about a
virus uncertainty about the future
working from home lack of social contact
no time with parents no time with
friends no time outdoors getting more
unhealthy eating [ __ ] food spending time
in the house being bombarded by news
media lack of information that we can
trust lack of news organizations that we
can trust lack of politicians that are
telling the truth complete loss of
confidence in all of that stuff and then
the icing on the top of the cake is
yup a war correct on top of it
insane bro
i've never thought about it this way but
now that you say it
i'm literally like oh [ __ ]
but the thing to think dudes you know
and for
anybody that's got through the last
couple of years
with their sanity even remotely intact
communities
can be pretty proud of themselves yeah
absolutely man you know it's
and that's the thing because it's not
it's not there's no glory attached to it
there's no prestige you don't get a blue
tick on twitter for doing this you don't
get any money in your bank account for
having done this but if you've been
somebody that's been there when one of
your friends has rang you and said man i
feel
i feel pretty shitty today i don't
really know what's going to happen with
my job or my girlfriend or my house or
my investments or whatever if you've
been the person that's been there or
even if you've just been the person
that's been the one ringing and you've
managed to make it through on the other
side i think that's something that you
should clap yourself on the back for
i feel a
blue ticker all the verification tickers
if you're married they're meaningless
it's a
i don't care if i was single i would
definitely want one bro okay look tom
let's bring this home man i really
appreciate you i appreciate the work
that you do
tell everyone where they should go if
they want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you put out
well you can find me on twitter
at i am tom nash
my channel is tom nash
youtube.comnashtv
you can also see me daily on a channel
called sense invest
s-e-n-t-s invest we have a daily show
called money talks with me and justin
which you've met
i think that show is going to be
brilliant we're on episode 15 and it's
going to be epic
and other than that
don't look for me anywhere else because
i don't want to be found
and i'm very intentional about it good
man brother thank you so much for today
later what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you